okay so we've been talking about the
Second Great Awakening and its context
in early 19th century America the Second
Great Awakening was this period of
religious revival that was kind of at
its Hotpoint in 1822 1840 and in the
last couple of videos we've been talking
about just the nature of the society
that produced the Second Great Awakening
particularly how they responded to
changes and how people related to each
other in business and also just broader
social changes like the expansion of
American democracy and the expansion of
American Territory west so in this last
video I want to talk about some of the
outgrowth of the Second Great Awakening
so why do we care so much that there was
this period of religious revival what
did it lead to in American life and
there are two major things that were
directly related to the Second Great
Awakening in this early 19th century new
religious movements in the United States
some of which are still with us today
and even more importantly for the time
period major reform movements including
the movement for abolition the end of
slavery which is going to lead to the
outbreak of the Civil War so let's look
a little bit closer at these two things
so as we've talked about the second
great awakening promoted both the idea
that one should try to create heaven on
earth and also a more democratic
approach to religion in general that it
didn't matter who you were if you were a
man a woman white black enslaved free
you were still entitled to a personal
relationship with God and a chance at
Salvation so one of the things that's
meant in this time period is that
there's just a lot of religious
experimentation a lot of new American
religions emerge at this time period
some of which are still with us today
some of which are not this here is a
representation of the shakers
which were a religious community of they
embrace kind of simplicity they
separated the sexes
they practice celibacy just as kind of
trying to make their daily lives more
pure and unfortunately the celibacy part
meant that they more or less died out by
the 1940s although there are a handful
of shakers who are still alive today and
they were called the shakers because
they would have these kind of ecstatic
religious experiences which you can see
are kind of similar to what happened in
the camp meetings so even though they
didn't have sex they would kind of get
out their ecstasy in this process of
these big circle dances which people
looked at and they said they seemed like
they were shaking so they were the
shakers on the other side of the
spectrum there was the Oneida community
which was led by a man named John
Humphrey Noyes and they preached the
idea that one should have no earthly
attachments basically and that meant
also to a spouse so they believed in was
called complex marriage or what we would
really call free love there was no such
thing as an individual marriage that
women and men could have sex with
whomever they pleased it's interesting
that approaches to sex were very central
to these religious movements and
probably the most important religious
movement to come out of this time period
was the Church of Jesus Christ of
latter-day saints
also known as the Mormons who were
founded by Joseph Smith in Rochester New
York and Smith had a vision that he was
visited by an angel who presented him
with gold plates and on these gold
plates was a new scripture called the
Book of Mormon and Smith's followers
really continued to be devoted to the
religion even though they faced a lot of
persecution particularly over their
early practice of polygamy until they
continued to move west under the
leadership of a second man Brigham Young
who took over after Smith was murdered
by an angry crowd in Illinois who then
led the Mormons to Utah where they
continued to be a major religious group
to this day
oh and one other interesting thing about
this is the Oneida community although it
itself did not survive one of the ways
that they made money as a community was
by making silverware and so Oneida
silverware is actually the descendant
company of this really interesting
communal experiment and they lasted I
believe until 2006 so if you ever had
Oneida silverware you were looking at an
artifact of a 19th century religious
movement so the last and probably the
most important part of the Second Great
Awakening that I want to talk about is
its influence on reform movements so let
me give myself a little bit more space
to right here there are several 19th
century reform movements that are tied
into the Second Great Awakening one of
these would be the temperance movement
which hopes to reduce and/or eliminate
people's consumption of alcohol and you
can kind of tie this back to the idea of
heaven on earth right how can you have a
stable family home how can you have a
godly society if everybody who's drunk
all the time I would say the most
important reform movement associated
with the Second Great Awakening was the
abolitionist movement and remember that
Harriet Beecher Stowe who wrote Uncle
Tom's Cabin which was the greatest
abolition or anti-slavery advertisements
in the world was the daughter of Lyman
Beecher one of the greatest preachers of
the Second Great Awakening and so as
people came to believe that everyone's
life was equally valuable they became
more and more involved in the idea that
slavery should not exist that people who
were enslaved had souls that were just
as worthy of salvation as anyone who was
already free and so they also saw this
as you know one of the perversions of
God's Word and a perversion of the
family which they saw as the central
unit of American democracy and
look anism so slavery should not exist
and people who were really motivated by
their faith in God and their faith and
trying to create heaven on earth in a
better society campaigned really
strenuously for the end of slavery and
ultimately were successful so this is a
really complex topic the Second Great
Awakening you know if we look back at
our web again we can see that this wave
of religious revival was connected in
all sorts of interesting ways to the
economic and political changes of the
time period and in its way led to all
sorts of different social changes so I
think it's a good example of how it's
sometimes really hard to separate things
that happened in the past into really
neat boxes right that oh there was
politics there was religion there was
culture there were economics but in many
ways they're all bound together in a
larger culture within which everyday
individuals navigated their lives and
it's also good to show us that sometimes
we don't exactly know why things
happened in the past we know that people
got really interested in religion in
this time period but historians have
differing ideas about why that might
have been some say that it was a form of
trying to control people as it was more
and more important to have a dutiful
workforce for a factory based industrial
society and some people say that maybe
it was just about demographic and
political shifts and who had power who
had money and who got to vote but we do
know that the Second Great Awakening and
these ideas of trying to improve America
to improve the world and to create
heaven on earth led to all sorts of
interesting things that are still with
us today including religious movements
and the end of slavery